the chance of a second breaks at
referendum is seemingly back on the
table within the past hour British prime
minister Theresa May said MPs will get
the chance to vote on another referendum
if they finally pass her withdrawal bill
which has of course been rejected a
number of times before may outline
several new concessions to her bill to
try and get it through on attempt number
four the revised deal will deliver on
the result of the referendum and only by
voting for the withdrawal agreement bill
that second reading can MPs provide the
vehicle Parliament needs to determine
how we leave the EU
so if MPs vote against the second
reading of this bill they are voting to
stop brexit if they do so the
consequences could hardly be greater
well let's go live now to Westminster
and artis Poli
Boyko who's been listening in to that
speech by the British PM a lot of ifs a
lot of buts
Polly talks about second referendums
cross-party
talks a lot going on what was your main
take from this well there's two big
headline kind of concessions there and
one is that there would be a vote on a
second referendum so MPs will get to
vote on whether there should be a second
referendum if this new withdrawal deal
passes in the House of Commons first so
it's very conditional and pretty risky I
think before the Prime Minister in terms
of delivering brexit the other big
concession that she made is that
Parliament would be able to vote on the
option of a customs union with the EU or
sticking to the deal that she's already
outlined with the EU in terms of a
customs arrangement but this was the
result of sort of her failing to push
through her withdrawal deal several
several times through Parliament to
begin with and then these six weeks have
failed talks of cross party negotiations
with the
labor party so this new brexit bill is
all about saying that she's changed it
in just enough hopefully for it to pass
in Parliament and she says the details
of it more details are going to be
fleshed out over the next few days and
announced to the public because she says
that you can't expect the MPs in
Parliament to vote on a deal they've
already rejected that's why she's made
quite a few changes to it and promises
with this new brexit bill that she hopes
will help to get it over the line she
said that the government's going to make
sure that it's aligned to Northern
Ireland this this deal because the big
problem for so many politicians with the
previous withdrawal bill that she failed
to get through was this issue this very
contentious issue of the Irish backstop
and you know she says that it's not
possible to remove the Irish backstop
from the agreement with the EU but it's
possible to promise to never have a need
for the backstop in the first place and
she also promised that any future trade
deals would be approved by MPs as well
she said the workers rights would be
aligned that environmental issues would
be the same as the EU because of
concerns that by not aligning the UK to
the EU these standards could slip and
that has been a concern of many remain
errs especially and she promised as
close as frictionless trade as possible
with the EU to keep up with agricultural
norms so there wouldn't be any
disruption to the supply chain and all
the farmers that work here and send
their goods to the EU and there was this
big customs compromise that I outlined
earlier but of course the headline
grabber is this option of a vote on a
second referendum if mp's passed the
withdrawal deal first so a bit of a
head-scratcher it does show you how much
of a mess really brexit has turned into
here in the UK but Teresa may we'll be
hoping that it's enough to get this new
ish deal over the line in Parliament but
will it be we'll know by the
week of June poly poker thanks so much
for talking us throughout from
Westminster live on the program let's go
through some of those issues that Polly
brought up with independent political
commentator Anthony webinar 3 welcome to
the program how likely is it Anthony
that Theresa Mays New Deal is going to
secure the backing of MPs because that's
what it seems that be trying to be all
things to all people here or am I wrong
well I think it's unlikely at the moment
and all the she's done so far is upset
some of her backbenchers who previously
were supportive of her I think it shows
that she's more caring about her own
political legitimate legacy of trying to
get something achieved at whatever cost
before she steps down as Prime Minister
rather than doing the right thing for
the country and it's hoped that the main
opposition party that they the party
will see through this and will not give
in to the blackmailing which is really
apparent in this set of proposals the
curvy the temptation for them is the the
very for the customs union they're all
being so agree but I don't think anyone
would believe it would be temporary and
of course as Polly mentioned the
referendum option and that will be seen
that as a huge betrayal by many people
across the country so yes doesn't really
seem to be anything there to get the DP
to change their minds
so will it all depends upon what the
Labour Party's attitude will be but
let's be frank and say that there's
nothing really significant here that
they're playing around with words
because the agreements itself can't be
changed
Teresa mayors and changes that she's
just giving Pohlman further options and
those options base
we mean that a proper prep set can be
kicked down the line well I suppose
there is a there is a big issue here
though for certain MPs will MPs who
support a second public vote and there's
quite a few of them in Parliament be
willing to vote for a maize deal in
order to secure another referendum well
nothing's impossible but of course
they've got to back deal
there are we may be said to object to
the protection with the EU environmental
legislation and protection of workers
rights oh I don't think that's a
particular problem is the fact that she
fundamentally hasn't changed anything
we're still going to be this blank
cheque of thirty nine billion given to
the EU without the south of the detailed
negotiations so I think there are a
major problems there and I fail to see
what is actually going to convince the
brexit is and it would be interesting to
see because I don't think there's
anything there which is going to get
sufficient remainders to tabac the deal
and the other thing is you have to look
at this in context of the elections this
Thursday a resume is trying to make her
party look as though they're trying to
achieve something on Brits it was if you
look at it in detail and people already
started to do that it is clear it means
nothing at all the only problem is that
her own cabinets have agreed to pass
this and it's not things that make the
Conservative Party look any good in the
country but the cabinet is so weak
they can't stand up to these sort of
tactics which are going on so if it
follows suit this fort attempt like all
the previous ones and gets rejected
where does that leave things does it
leave a No Deal the WTO terms a much
more likely prospect well yes they need
to be much more brought on the table and
this is one of the things which is
concerning trees amazed she's so
desperate that because she knows that
but it's huge support for No Deal breaks
it and that's shown by the support for
the break they thought secretly polls
for the elections and what the birthday
party needs to do is to give a little
bit more detail about the advantages of
the No Deal breaks it and I think that
might well come over the next couple of
days but there's certainly a big public
support for it and you know obviously
we'll have to see what happens on on
Thursday but many people see that as a
sort of opinion poll or mini referendum
on the need to get out of the EU as was
voted for the 2016 referendum okay not
to put you on the spot but just a quick
prediction do you think the UK will be
out of the European Union come Halloween
III I really would hope so there's a lot
of things going on there's a court
action going on at the moment where it's
argued that we did legally leave the EU
on the 29th of March so that could very
much have an effect and it also depends
upon what happens with the the two main
parties because it's a tea main parties
both got elected on honoring the 2016
referendum results and the Labour Party
you've got a completely backtrack on on
what they were were voted in on and
Conservative Party have also so it's a
question
there's a new leader the Conservative
Party will they then decide say Allah
what people voted for and what will
happen with with the Labour Party
because at the moment of the public see
the Labour Party is not really knowing
which way to turn and being more Romania
orientated Antony a few intriguing weeks
ahead I'm sure you'll agree independent
political commentator Anthony Weber live
on RT International
you